des agents hérissant rappelle au sol
leurs collègues en renfort
ils font face à des agents
pénitentiaires dans le rôle de détenus
qui refusent de rejoindre leur cellule
après la promenade dix minutes de
démonstration pour séduire un jeune
public
la pénitentiaire a une force dissuasive
qui s'appelle l'équipe régionale
intervention de sécurité ce n'était pas
le cas au pas auparavant et surtout les
personnels de leiris ce sont des anciens
personnes de l'administration
pénitentiaire qui connaissent le
fonctionnement des détenus pour la
première fois en france un domaine
pénitentiaire ouvre ses portes aux
visiteurs
objectif exposer les différents métiers
en maison d'arrêt un milieu carcéral peu
attrayant et qui peine à recruter
c'est un métier qui est peu connu on
n'entend jamais parler nous c'est un
monsieur qui donne pas envie de bellevue
travail en prison de travail enfermé
c'est un métier qui donne pas envie on
va pas se mentir donc mais comme on dit
souvent chez nous on a appris à aimer
notre métier parce qu'il sait pas que de
la répression il ya aussi de
l'association il ya aussi du travail
psychologique parce qu'on parle avec les
personnes d'ethnie on est au contact de
la population pour attirer de nouvelles
recrues
l'administration pénitentiaire s'appuie
sur plusieurs démonstrations
l'extraction judiciaire d'un détenu
menacé à sa sortie de prison ou encore
le processus de recherche de matières
explosives entre ces jeunes destinés aux
métiers de la sécurité et le personnel
les échanges sont constructifs
car il faut transmettre et casser les
idées reçues on peut faire une carrière
l'administration pénitentiaire on peut
commencer comme surveillant est terminée
directeur l'administration pénitentiaire
est une institution où l'ascenseur
social comme l'on dit encore une réalité
à partir d'aujourd'hui
l'inscription au concours de surveillant
pénitentiaire est ouverte
l'administration espère que cette
journée aura suscité des vocations